welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and ant-man of the wasp quantum
mania's new trailer footage shown at d23
posed a huge question that reshapes the
multiverse saga and tells us why kang's
big debut is coming in an ant-man movie
the stakes have never been higher for
what baskin robbins will find out now i
was lucky to be in the room to see this
footage as well as a footage for loki's
season two and i think i have a pretty
good idea for how this will all fit
together i'm gonna break it all down for
you so the quantum media footage shown
at d23 is an expanded version of what
was shown at comic-con in july it opens
with scott hope and cassie on a road
trip listening to the audiobook of
scott's new autobiography look out for
the little guy in which scott recounts
the moment hulk d aged him into a baby
and end game then it transitions into
this kind of fur stacked montage footage
that said to james taylor's your smiling
face with scott's voice over narrating i
used to ask myself a lot of questions
scott you're an ex-con how are you an
avenger why are you time traveling with
captain america that doesn't make sense
but the answer to that question is
exactly why kang wants him we see
scott's old boss from baskin-robbins
dale also working at baska robbins is
actor reuben rabasa who came into our
lives in a sketch from tim robinson's i
think you should leave uh any other
ideas stinky
what here where bossy yells at scott
thank you spider-man then cassie says
she's been working on the secret science
project with hank and with hope and she
tells scott so when you were all gone
those five years i started reading
grandpa hank's old journals and i got
really into the quantum realm so she
shows scott and janet a device that
she'd made saying if i had something
like this i could have found you it's a
communication device that cassie says
works like a two-way radio but janet is
suddenly concerned and she says wait a
minute you're sending a signal down to
the quantum realm turn it off this
device activates on its own emitting a
blue orb that sucks in cassie and the
others now what follows is the trippy
quantum realm imagery that i described
in july including cameos of bill
murray's character and a mechanized
modoc but the most crucial expansion is
scott's moment with kang kang's voice
says time isn't what you think if you
want to get out of here i'm the only
shot you have as before scott says you
made a big mistake i'm an avenger kang
responds you're an avenger have i killed
you before but now the scene goes on and
scott asks what kang says they all blend
together after a while scott asks who
are you and kang says just a man who has
lost a lot of time like you but we can
help each other with that someone stole
something from me and you're the only
one who can steal it back so do we have
a deal we see that cassie is kang's
captive and she silently shakes her head
to tell her dad not to take the deal so
scott says no i don't think we do and
now kang uses the kind of telekinesis to
slam scott against a wall and bind him
to it hey tell scott you're out of your
league ant-man so this confirms why kang
is arriving in an ant-man movie like the
previous two ant-man films this will
again be a heist plot a follow-up to the
time heist of avengers end game ant-man
of all the avengers is the top expert in
covert theft cracking impossible saves
stealing the impossible from pymtech to
hacking iron man's arc reactor to steal
the tesseract but this time rather than
seeking infinity stones throughout
history scott lang will have the
opportunity to regain the five years he
lost with his daughter cassie from the
master of time by helping kang find
something that was stolen from him and
stealing it back so now really the most
important question heading into the
multiverse saga is what did kang lose so
if scott can steal an infinity stone
there are any number of valuable
physical objects in the mcu that kang
would need his help in acquiring we
could start in the junk drawer or the
tva that is filled with interesting
pruned items that might have been
confiscated from this kang besides those
duplicate infinity stones there's the
french legion diana medal the hoeness
wagner baseball card if we consider that
he remains was a rival kang variant to
the kang quantomania these two being
enemies who are trying to block each
other all the time really anything in
the void or in the tva headquarters
could be something he remains kept away
from this kang like frog in a jar the
thanos copter the sphinx which remember
was kang's time travel vessel in the
fantastic war comics that's how he got
back to ancient egypt this kang in
quantum realm might want scott to hijack
the sphinx to steal his old time machine
for him the loki's season 2 footage
reveals kihui kwan is joining the cast
as tva archivist of some kind managing a
vault of rare objects one of his items
could be what kang wants scott to steal
remember loki's season one ended with
the tva rebooted with the timekeeper
statues replaced with the looming statue
of a different kang and the loki's
season 2 footage shows loki using a time
stick to prune back a mural wall of the
timekeepers to reveal multiple golden
faces of kang each of them the size of
the timekeeper faces in the courtroom so
if this tva is now ruled over by a kang
it's hard to see why kang would need
scott lang to steal something from the
tva that he's already in charge of so
instead what kang lost might actually be
something in a different location that
he still would not have access to like
the citadel because remember the citadel
was not connected directly to the tva it
could only be accessed by conquering
eliath goliath being an interdimensional
beast that he remains uniquely was able
to tame and use to conquer all the other
kangs so it stands to reason that the
other kangs might not be able to access
he who remains citadel and that citadel
lower level had four statues originally
one of which was shattered a mysterious
detail that the production designer said
would be addressed in a later title i
think that statue is broken from a past
conflict that will be addressed in this
quantum media film that citadel and
concept art at least was originally
going to contain various trophies from
the mcu including an iron man helmet but
the lost item could be as simple as kang
just wants the original tim pad the
magical quantum tech that he remains had
attached to his fingers perhaps the
first device that any nathaniel richards
variant used to manipulate the timelines
now alternatively if we frame this
question of what kang lost in terms of
the central mystery to a classic film
like citizen kane the question being
what is rosebud the answer to that
question was spoiler warning for a 80
year old movie rosebud was charles
foster kane's childhood sled
representing his lost childhood and his
lost innocence but if you really know
your hollywood history naming this lead
rosebud was also a low blow insult by
orson welles at william randolph hearst
the real world media magnet that kane
was a total satire of really citizen
kane was a total hit piece on william
randolph hers and in real life hearst's
mistress was actress marion davies who
was also parodied in the film by the
actress susan alexander and hearst
reportedly nicknamed marion davies
maidenhood rosebud so i don't know
perhaps the most interesting rosebud for
citizen kang would be a lost love i have
speculated ravonna rensslayer kang's
love in the comics who was shown with a
kang easter egg her hunter designation
being a23 for avengers 23 the comic
issue where rensselaer is introduced in
a romance with kang is explored really
every tva could be represented by some
physical token like rentslayer's high
school pen mobius is jet ski and if
scott's able to steal that item he could
in essence capture their soul but i'll
throw another theory out there miss
tara strong confirmed miss minutes is
returning in season two of loki and miss
minutes has always been implied to have
a mysterious backstory she is after all
a creepy ai of unknown composition she
could jump on and off screens i didn't
see any hollow projectors beaming her
there is she magic is she in their minds
there's so many questions left about
miss minutes it's possible that she has
a clock source somewhere in the tba or
in the citadel that can be tracked down
and stolen but i'll pose the question to
you what do you think kang lost that he
needs stolen back you can follow me on
tick tock instagram and twitter at avos
follow new rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you